I'll tell you what I'm gonna do okay I'm
gonna take your brother who's a smartass
that sends me texts yeah like open for
me on the road I'm doing stand-up now
[ __ ] like my brother says I he says [ __ ]
like that it's a nice it just sent me a
picture of him smiling I'm gonna smack
him around with an open hand for no
reason I'm gonna bully him push him down
push him into the bush it's no dude yeah
I'm gonna get his get his knees all
scraped up dude and you're gonna sit and
watch and all you're gonna do is go
don't know look Dawg I'm not gonna do
that don't and I'm not gonna listen no
I'm gonna I'm gonna shove your brother
around make him cry and I'm gonna get if
he has money in his pockets I'm gonna
reach in his pockets I'm gonna pull out
the money I'm take his keys the throw is
keys somewhere for no reason well so I'm
gonna bully him no you're not gonna do
you ain't gonna do jack
no dude right that's not true you're
gonna do [ __ ] job dude don't impose
him a will honor all right on my yeah
okay dolia sure come up I'm gonna
chest-bump you know I'm a knows gonna be
on your nose you can smell my breath
okay and I'm gonna go what right no what
no you're not no you're not you're gonna
go right and you're gonna fall on your
brother I'm not keep and weep with him
and you guys gonna clutch each other mmm
cry and then you know what's gonna
happen I'm gonna fun Oh
peel out no your car nope and then
you're gonna pop up and you're gonna say
that's what you're getting
hey Crypt Keeper hey I don't like this
ageist humor you don't text while you're
doing our podcast yeah I do dude I was
texting to get me a tea call me with an
emergency I sent it to so many people
look at your shitty posture see this
place man whole trainer wouldn't
appreciate sit out sit like this to like
hey hey Chris did you train have you on
a diet - yeah dude I ate so many [ __ ]
ice creams last night why
why wanted that I mind when I get when I
when I when I get a boner i faint a lot
because of the blood I lose a lot of
blood about it yeah I just go oh you are
okay people watch how is that a Sun Dial
they go like doc hey no oh no can I ask
you a question maybe so you are are you
anemic dude not because I might color
you have you know what it is knowing
alabaster why it's not it's porcelain
white yeah is what it is in it but it's
it's very a lot of kings and queens are
that because they don't go because of
the workers go outside so you know you
don't really see the Sun the workers go
have you had your vitamin D check no I
go I went I was in the Sun you asking me
a question right sorry bro
sorry man it's all good but we made a
mistake together right right well yeah I
guess okay all right cool
cuz I was answering a question you
interrupted me so we made a mistake
together right yeah okay celebrities
100% who's the most famous celebrity
you've had reach out to you Christ okay
like I don't know that's Christ true
Christ what did he say he goes like this
thank you for taking what I've given you
and putting it
you know exponentially into the world he
goes like this
fine even I even the all-seer even I
didn't have any idea that you could take
it this far he goes like that
so he was singing the way they do like
the yeah yes I don't know and it was
like when I originally put you on this
earth I didn't think that you would
exceed my expectations but you did
it goes like that it's like what that's
incredible yeah I mean II bestow
anything any rewards so yeah he gave me
these because he was like here are some
glasses because you're going since your
faces in the front of you and the past
is behind you and the future is way far
ahead it's gonna get shiny and bright
and you need these sunglasses to shield
your vision so he gave me these
sunglasses that's a main I know he's
[ __ ] weird if you know did he say
anything about the fact that I'll be in
Orlando Saturday's two tickets are going
Super Saturday practically made Rafi
what he said was if you're a fan of
Christmas Chris D'Elia
definitely go outside of the Orlando
Improv and pick get that Brian counts
going to be there that's what they said
right said yeah Christ say I didn't say
why I think Allen is my face no no it's
like this if you need supplies I've got
markers and whiteboards does he make but
so far he oh no he go he said he said
that fellow well not are you your hair
and it's okay but you are losing your
[ __ ] hair oh that's funny
don't don't
common from you hey I'm the ocean glass
of water
why are you so wet that's a Terrell
annoying hey well I'm a [ __ ] forest
fire matches what the [ __ ] are you doing
alright I have some hair i'm follically
challenged on lie down I don't like I
don't like that bro
get up hey real quick Chris are those
jeans or sweats these are [ __ ]
both bro I do hybrid yeah pick cation
yeah ginger sweats
you know it's [ __ ] up I had a great
drop in knowledge but it's on my phone
my phone just died I'm so disrespectful
all right let's wrap the hey back on
black guys yeah there's no great
dropping knowledge shut the [ __ ] up hey
I'm smarter [ __ ] dropping knowledge
ladies and gentlemen thank you so much
for crystal thank for come on what you
guys doing listen to what's he called
congratulations iTunes everywhere he's
out of his garage with his my dog with
his [ __ ] hey can't be a guest on
congratulations
I'll have to check on what I decided
complete waste of time
hey can't do it I'm booked you're off
booked with who you me
I got me on it tinder and he's not hey
ho yo hear what shoes food was in the
way dude hey these shoes are white shoes
are that why do they shot the [ __ ]
scenes in Game of Thrones we're [ __ ]
Jon Snow is right around the mountains
on these shoes and you're gonna step on
them I bear in the way I apologize I
didn't mean step on you can con say
something nice about me okay
please Chris I think what they're so you
had a rapper stuck your [ __ ] foot
before yeah oh yeah you guys [ __ ]
sabotage me dude this was on the ground
already we did not stop you know but is
that Laffy Taffy you know it's a [ __ ]
it's a water bottle leaders don't the
cult leaders take themselves very
seriously and they take and they get
really mad at any slight see what's
happening with you guys put hoursa
sabotage me and made me look stupid we
did it Chris nobody did that you guys
did do that see see what power his head
and honestly if we were if we were
chilling outside you'd have to go back
to the LA Kevin and do some chores like
so you do have punishment well it's our
punishment it's just help you're helping
now and you you're a sweeper I'm a
sweeper here you go enjoy bold
landscaping duty so say something nice
okay
about day and then all right better be
genuine all right and it better be
positive Chris I like Brendan's attitude
I think he's got a great attitude and I
think he's a go-getter and
I think he [ __ ] won't stop and he's a
[ __ ] juggernaut thanks man
no problem in any sense of the word to
juggernaut yeah he's a juggernaut okay
great
yeah good stuff talk about me yeah you
honestly know be nice Chris I'm gonna
positive I'm gonna positive day remember
that time we went to dinner with a bunch
of people and we were at this restaurant
Laurel tavern or Laurel something sure
Laurel hardware hardware that's what is
sheriff I think I was there right yeah
you were okay and Bryan at the end of
the meal hey Steve nice meal nice meal
blood friends what a lot of laughs
yeah Brian says hey to me he says
secretly pay for this whole meal that's
and it was nice that you thought of
everyone else that we should that should
be taken care of okay well I do remember
that's not very don't know if it's
positive cause negative being a dick no
but it happened I was there that did
happen yeah Brian was like offering what
if he was trying to don't know because
you were poor yeah yo people we bear
I've never met it was because you were
bragging about all your money and I
thought maybe you should put your money
where your mouth is and I hate for it
because you bragging you barely ate
anything I did and I paid for it and
didn't make a den but I just thought it
was nice no no you know haunt B it was
so happy with yourself bro don't say hi
I know dude we ordered a lot of food at
a very nice place good wine is good wine
I don't even drink yeah you suggested
that I pay for everyone right and I did
okay okay and the interesting thing
about that is it didn't make a dent
right right now right now it didn't make
it they make it Dan right but it
bothered you it's so obnoxious I was
listeners rightly so because you're
bragging about the money you make it's
so obnoxious but because it can all be
taken away from you and said that you
are like boxing and sparring yeah you're
getting hit in the head sometimes that's
a real bad idea for you
it's a bad thing to be on it gets him
really angry I mean you have you know
well okay why is it get you angry it
doesn't get me angry I don't like to
hear I just don't get why you want to
get hit in the head especially 50 he
wanted to talk to me he gets so mad he's
like I'm not even talking to you about
this no I wasn't he won't I'll ask him a
question like a technique question he's
like I'm not answering I'm not talking I
get that I'd rather tell you I get why
he wouldn't want it doesn't matter yeah
yeah it's like right I remember I got
embarrassed with him because I see I
said should I get the plant protein of
the whey protein in my smoothie and he
looks at me goes it doesn't matter does
it though yeah [ __ ] I'll never ask
[ __ ] dumb questions like that hey now
you can't do unto all you're not getting
in the hair how good a schism I'm really
young yeah well you're 30 very young I'm
yeah but and you look 37 right sooner
I'm saying not to be a dick but you know
that right
you look 30 you say like every minute 37
you an a.1 you are chock full you're
you're 37 cup is chock full to the brim
you're spilling oh I get this sometimes
for the Vitamix of course you say of
course the day I turned 38 how old will
I look I'll tell you this you I don't
yeah when you're 38 the day to 38 you
look 38 okay you're like it's a bad
thing
I'm just saying that it and it is the
way you're saying it is a bad thing and
it's making me angry no I don't throw 38
for a long time I just turned 37 but you
got to stop saying that no I know but
you could mule you could mule drugs in
those [ __ ] eyelids you could mule
drugs in those saggy that's why I showed
you your eyes man all right oh no you're
making me sad I know and don't cut your
hair because there goes that career no
dude I'm up on meth every day that'll be
less detrimental to your career I
probably have to [ __ ] cut my hair
soon do some kind of [ __ ] cool part
probably okay some dope right here all
asked me to do so dragon what don't stop
it throwing your phone when you see my
back ripple and I pull myself up like a
champ like a chimp through 30 times fast
while talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a gets a gift it's a gift